so here's what wikipedia says skinwalker
ranch also known as Sherman Ranch is a
property located on approximately five
hundred twelve acres southeast of
Ballard Utah that is reputed to be the
site of paranormal and UFO related
activities its name is taken from the
skinwalker of Navajo legend concerning
malevolent witches all right so here's
the steal your skin you know I I can you
just here's the thing vices trying to
sell you this story about like here's an
interesting place but they don't tell
you anything about it before they just
start talking about driving there and
that's frustrating to me yeah well uh
basically they say I mean look I'll be
fair they did talk a little bit about
cattle mutilations and stuff like that
and they say like you know here's here
I'll just read this little clip about
some dude according to Keller and Knapp
they saw or investigated evidence of
close to 100 incidents that include
vanishing and mutilated cattle sightings
of unidentified flying objects are orbs
large animals with piercing red eyes
that they say were unscathed when struck
by bullets invisible objects emanating
destructive magnetic fields among those
involved were a retired US Army criminal
Colonel John B Alexander who
characterized the NID SSCI effort as an
attempt to get hard data using standard
scientific approach however the
investigators admitted to quote
difficulty obtaining evidence consistent
with scientific publication and then you
have like you know cattle mutilations
and stuff so I gotta I gotta be honest I
don't know if there's too much we can
actually get into other than they start
you know actually talking about what
this place is so I'll do this do you
want it you want to take it at them and
you know tell us what's going on well
let's let's go over to this this is you
want to reset the skin while I want to
talk about the the true skinwalkers this
this is a terrifying image but this is
what the Navajo believe that the
skinwalkers are they they can turn into
animals and they can control you by just
making eye contact so they make eye
contact they got you so they say never
make eye contact with the skinwalker
like you're gonna no close your eyes
what you know this photo looks like it
looks like a dude put a mask on the back
of his head and is just like crab
walking on a side street you're right it
does
in Walker bro but okay okay it says
beware a stolen face yeah okay you want
you want you want to explain those what
a skinwalker is oh yeah this is cool
stuff I love this stuff skinwalkers are
actually known as witches in the Navajo
culture and they used to be human so
they're no longer humans and they want
your face so I guess they'll steal your
very skin from you man that is it is
pretty frightening this they can
transform into any animal including you
so it says that's how they absorb
themselves is by you know making eye
contact with you the Navajo are let's
see the Navajo tribe is notorious for
not talking about skinwalkers to
outsiders I guess they're they're
frightened yeah of Supernatural
repercussions Navajo Voldermort there's
too much discussion about them like
though oh you talked about us too much
we're coming for you let me let me ask
you something though I know this is
about superstition but do like does like
Christianity have these kinds of things
I don't think so
like do religion you don't know like you
know what I mean yeah it's kind of weird
that like a culture would I guess I
guess Eastern European stuff they have
like vampires and oh this is uh this is
the ranch actually they do they they
talk about the ranch here in Utah they
said there's a ranch in Utah called
skinwalker ranch because there's been so
many sightings interesting so I guess
there's been sightings of skinwalkers
what what do you what is it like you see
a dude crab walkin on a side street near
a skinwalker dad I can tell you you know
what you know Mothman is yeah the
Mothman thing like basically there's
like the legend where is it like
Kentucky or something of like this giant
Mothman monster and what they actually
think it is is just like an owl
and what happens is because people have
bad depth perception at night yeah they
can't tell how close or far away it is
so it's really it'll be really close to
the vehicle but because it's dark
they'll think it's far away and really
maybe a big and the foot human sized
thing with glowing eyes you're like that
was an owl
that was just an owl there are massive
owls in Arizona where I was that and
it's they're they're huge they're like
four feet tall owls you know yeah they
can take small dogs and fly away with
them you know kind of bums me out that
could be part of it
okay it's kind of bums me out that like
you know a thousand years ago there's to
be these really cool stories of like
legendary beasts and monsters yeah like
you play Skyrim now or like some kind of
RPG mm-hmm and you're like whoa I just
found the legendary beast and you gotta
fight its giant dragon and these come
from the general stories of like I know
someone bumped into a bear and they were
like did you come back to the village
and they're like you understand this
creature it's claws were so strong it
ripped a tree out of the ground and I
was shocked and it's like the first time
someone actually encountered like a
grizzly like you know they started
expanding and exploring nowadays we just
we just know everything so thanks life
gonna be boring it's the grizzly bear
yeah it's not a skinwalker it's it's a
crab walking guy no it's a wolf it's a
coyote with mange yeah you know I mean
it's like it was a creepy hairless
creature walk it looked at me and
prowled it that's a coyote with mange
congratulations well let's let's read a
little bit I'm almost upset that they
stole skinwalker cuz it feels like it
has nothing to do with the Navajo
skinwalker right it's like they just
kind of like oh you know what this works
I gotta cool it's it's catchy and you
know it's like clickbait almost the
clickbait of urban legends yeah exactly
well let's let's I grab a little bit
more of what's going out these these
look at this look at this guy yeah
basically aware went into a wolf is this
is that what they think it is and you
know it's funny it's like clearly a
Navajo guy mm-hmm so it's like you don't
see the Navajo talking about you know
like blonde dudes from Europe like
showing up with claymores and like
swords you know like rails it's like
their legends are them it was probably
just the guy who is a a jerk like he's
just a jerk yeah and they were like
you're a skinwalker dude don't call me a
skinwalker bro you're so rude are we are
we gonna get in trouble for like auntie
Navajo bigotry all right here let me
they don't talk about it so we'll never
know I'm gonna read a little bit this so
um they do talk about the skinwalker
ranch I almost don't I don't really care
about that vais article anyway they say
the word in the Navajo language is Yi
Nell do she the word translates to he
who walks on all fours which really
makes the next fact that much more
horrific
skinwalkers can run far
greater distances than normal people
they're said to be able to run for 200
miles at a time at number nine stay away
from graveyards skinwalkers liked to
hang out there while they dig up graves
quickly you know I gotta say man it just
sounds like a coyote the main just like
digging in the dirt
you're like nothing really yeah yeah if
you guys don't know what mange is it's
basically a hare disease and they become
hairless but why dig up a grave some
skinwalkers can take the powder from
corpses and then use the dust as poison
on their victims oh okay I guess that
would work I mean disease I'll read the
next one here when they're not
transformed into animals witnesses have
described skinwalkers as hollowed-out
creatures that look a little like dogs
and more like a wolf with mange dude I
swear to God well feel like you called
it little like dogs it's a coyote with
mange yeah skinwalkers aren't and that's
why also too like Chupacabra mm-hmm like
people see these little hairless
monsters like what is it's like it's
mange dude it's a disease animal and not
only that but like some there could be
like a I don't know a dog with like a
genetic deformity and it's got no hair
so you want to become a skinwalker I
like that can I turn to animals there
are many different theories on how they
came to be but the most prevalent speaks
of an official ceremony where people
become skinwalkers through a gathering
with specific charms and chants one of
the rich one of the ritual acts to
become a skinwalker involves killing and
then eating someone close to them up to
goodness by performing this act the
soon-to-be skinwalkers lose any humanity
left in them beware once you're a
skinwalker you can't undo it you know
what's your cannibal you can't undo it
right through yeah like that guy from an
ax murderer you know about that guy from
CNN who ate brain reza aslan no yeah he
hate brain ropes yeah we'll talk about
that I'm gonna we're gonna talk a little
about that they say maybe he's a
skinwalker is that an insult about
someone close to me an ends Reza Aslan
is a Navajo skinwalkers okay brain if
you can get past their endurance
shape-shifting abilities and possible
coven and said that you can kill a
skinwalker by calling them by their true
priests skinwalker name dude that would
suck you dead name them you dead could
you imagine like if you became a
skinwalker and you're all like super
powerful and then someone's like oh hey
Adam can you grab
all right I'm now going to just for some
reason include a portion well hold on
let's do this let's do this hilarious oh
but wait wait did you see that you're
safe if you don't invite them in or did
say wait what number twelve skinwalkers
aren't allowed to enter home unless
invited dude what's up with that though
know that this Lynch is going on with
that most most things alright their
empires same thing innit right so I
think we explained it rabies rabies
rabies I think they would go right in if
the door was open no no no rabies man so
one of the one of the theories as to
like vampires is there's a dis an
affliction you know what it's called
production friend I'm not gonna call you
a chimp anymore humans with rabies know
that so there's there's an affliction
that makes your like you get dehydrated
so your skin gets really like your face
gets really gaunt and your eyes look
sunken yeah and it makes your gums
recede so your teeth are really long I
forgot it's called but that's like I
don't know somebody watching on google
it but that was basically like people
thought you know you'd see these frail
pale people with long teeth and that was
vampires but there's another legend that
like biting someone infects them comes
from rabies and so if a human had rabies
and they weren't completely you know
like for gone yeah they'd come to your
house visibly infected right and they
wouldn't enter without permission like a
still microphone because there was still
a decent human because there's still a
person yeah so you know and and then and
then like so yeah it's like this is
interesting that they would I don't
guess they shape-shift I don't know
where a lot of that comes from but it's
interesting how there's like symp
there's overlaps to these legends and
myths of these strange creatures yep and
how they become like almost magical like
it goes from literally someone seeing
something to understand like a disease
and then over time evolves into now we
have movies of like sexy vampires like
glowing and like yeah girl I'm like I
know right so weird right could you
think think about that like oh no but
think about this on the long enough
timeline could you imagine like the
origins of the vampire myth is this like
Haggard looking six
year-old man with like no teeth cuz he
got rabies he's got rabies and then he's
like oh what rabies was he's foaming at
the mouth and he's like shaking
violently and then that slowly evolved
to what's his face Robert Pattinson
whatever his name is going like sup girl
like we turn a decrepit old man with no
teeth into a sexy vampire I don't know
man or werewolves too you know right or
like even if the vampire myth was the
people with like that disease where
they're like teeth are like pulled back
and they're like now we're just like
making is isn't like basically every
vampire show about sexy vampires now
yeah what was that the Vampire Diaries
do you ever watch that no it's just sexy
vampires yeah and it's like sexy
vampires the protagonists tend to be
like early 20s women who like have the
difficult choice of whether they should
be with a vampire who oh he's just so
dangerous like a moment he could bite my
neck this is actually funny like
thinking about it like it's not just
that we've gone from like Haggard
diseased rabid old men into like buff
sexy men but that the narrative changed
from like fighting off evil right like
it used to be like start of the vampire
like Nosferatu was this evil being and
like the valiant like you know that van
Helsing would take the stake no he'd
finish you off and now it's the 20 year
old college co-ed who's like I don't
want to be with someone so evil but he's
just so dreamy
like how did the ner the story narrative
change you know I mean well the movie I
don't remember the name of it but it's
it was pretty awesome
which one asked for a to know it was a
last Twilight you're a big fan no it was
the actual like vampire movie of Dracula
or something and it was like the story
of how he only accepted it because his
people were yeah like he went to like
the ancient vampire yeah I think it's
called regular yeah I think it is like
that man it was pretty cool was like
alright and they were and they were my
only did it
yeah it was a monster and he was like I
am the monster and I'm you can have my
power and he's like I don't even want
your power like but I need it to save my
people so it was kind of like a
reluctant
yeah reluctant but he did it anyway and
it was cool
I'll give you that one a little
interesting but even when it's ladies
like underworld sexy vampires yeah sexy
but Kate Beckinsale is is like a very
attractive lady so I will accept this
but could you imagine laid same same
thing
yeah blade school that the blades Marvel
though could you imagine like going back
in time to like the very early vampire
legends and being like this is what
you've created and showing them like a
hundred years from now well not a
hundred by a thousand years much less
and they're gonna be like those creepy
monstrous men who live in the in the
tombs who come out at night and attack
my children and suck their blood
actually look at the breasts on this
woman they're very you know maybe like
you know what all right it's actually
it's kind of funny because if you think
about how like werewolf and vampire for
some reason in pop culture today and
even witches and wizards
you know like look at the wizard Wizard
of Oz with witches they're green
hook-nosed with like moles and you get
Harry Potter and it's like fanciful fun
and little gnomes and I get it
Voldemort's like basically you know
wizard Hitler but so they're they're bad
stuff but it's like even Harry Potter is
with witches and wizards are happy fun
you dancing around when witches used to
be like I don't mean like Wiccans like
pagans but I mean like the actual fear
of witches who would like you know kill
you or somewhere or steal your skin
that's that's what skinwalkers are the
Navajo witches I have a theory it's
gonna get us demonetized
but I want to tell you anyway oh you
know Incubus is yeah it's like a devil
that comes to like you know convinced
you to do stuff right then Incubus about
like a sexy thing oh it's a sex demon
yeah
bangs women oh okay yeah it was a little
off you know the succubus is I can
assume it's the opposite sex yes I have
a theory here's what I'm imagining okay
so a succubus is a female demon that
like tricks men and then steals their
life force through sex an incubus is
like the same thing but a man for a
woman right okay my theory is like I'm
imagining it's like four or five hundred
years ago and there's like a dude
cheating on his wife and he's in bed
with his like young beautiful woman
mm-hmm
wife comes in and she's like Oh Harold
what are you doing and goes she's a
demon a succubus she tricked me kill her
and so then they kill her right yeah and
then you have basically the the other
way around is the one with the guy
mm-hmm and when she gets caught cheating
the husband walks in and the guy gets up
she's like he's a demon I think he
tricked me kill him yeah so it's like
just an easy easy out
yeah and so now we have these legendary
demons but really it's just like just
people making up stuff yeah over there
but yeah I mean you know you think about
how gullible people were back then
when they thought a coyote with mange
would be like some fanciful demon but
he's pretty much tell anybody anything
it's true yeah you ever see that movie
the invention of lying no but I keep
seeing it and I would like to watch it I
like Ricky Gervais yeah it's Ricky
Gervais and it's a movie about a world
where no one can lie and basically one
day for some reason he lies mm-hmm it's
a good movie I mean well I'll say this I
wouldn't necessarily call it a good
movie it's a really interesting concept
though okay so it's like basically I
don't want to ruin the movie for anybody
who didn't see it so I'll just be like
very light um basically he goes to the
bank he can't pay his rent mm-hmm and
they tell him the computers are down and
he doesn't have enough money in his bank
out to pay his rent so he's like I'm
gonna be homeless and then she does well
the computers down how much money did
you have and he goes
I had $800 and then she goes oh the
computers back on like that was the
first lie ever told yeah and then she's
like wait a minute no you don't it must
be a mistake and then she gives him the
money because there's no lying right and
so then basically he goes through this
like basically anyone will believe
anything so he starts creating crazy
ideas he basically creates a religion
yeah it's cool moving all right so I
think we're how it was created
religion well I mean I think you know
without deviating into a whole nother
sin because I want to I wanna get some
of these super chats right right I think
I actually I think religion was the
first science interesting so it starts
with what we would call general
superstition but it was always an
attempt by humans to explain the world
around them
when humans knew basically nothing they
looked at the Stars and they would try
and explain the world to the best of
their abilities yeah
when humans knew very little it was like
you know the the power of the Stars and
the lights above us and the things they
couldn't understand mm-hmm would fit
into a narrative that could be somewhat
predictable yeah so it's like yeah I
don't know seems like the display thing
randomly changes for some reason don't
ask me why but but yeah so I look at
religions you know they're they're very
much it trying to explain things and and
here's like an interesting bit of a
tidbit I was I was a wondering why it
was that these Abrahamic religions don't
eat pork you know for the most part now
like Judaism and Christianity they're
kind of cool with it but like back in
the day they're like not you can't eat
it because Pig can be parasitic or
diseased and so so the idea is that back
way back when pigs were very likely to
be sickly I need to get sick from eating
them yeah so they basically said don't
eat them and that that was their
explanation that like to them they
thought it was a punishment or something
and you shouldn't do it because they're
but they literally say they're unclean
so yeah
you